it is will the site
this ball relief after 2 weeks intense
negotiation
budgets compromising cats witse
[Applause]
we go the attraction with the brito this
camp is in the lungs it is not easy to
find agreement can it that is even
specific
ansel technique old what  is this
circonstances every single step for work
is and peak active with the part 6 a world
je implementing finance the 2014 harry's
climbing grammont
james will with global temperature and
crisis to below to agree celcius
this renovation knew generation house the
responsibility to show how week here  already
plans livable
i keep my show de wybertjes co2 and
here who show we do that symbol under
the hall on-site the box upping the switches
also criticism
activism hoping for more ambitious
climate els f-two signed with any point
that is a carbon pro  fighter ii celcius
and the war ghost ship the wife on fossil
fuels
annie the tuber disaster my extra learn
fossil few countries hours locks games
hold
i think d  at die to this ever kind of
medina help me if you were having
science
how before heard what was and everywhere
nice leadership of new york in june
as well and getting a mission to team
girls with credit to work has become a
voice for the younger generation  my
inspiring children wars the world the
strike of chair in protests climate
change
shihan sjaak boards the the car sat the
conference
you seoul on your children already have for
els and jet yo stealing the future in
from too far away ice until you start
focusing on what  needs to be done
we had then what is political
lip gloss mole
there is still hope
[Applause]
climbers active ghost jan aan will much
world leader is h20 and shows your
photo frame
[Music]
[Applause]